[Music]
they made an influential list and some
people are pissed
yeah fox news crushed another year-end
list blowing away the competition in
2021 mediaite has released their annual
list of most influential in news media
and shockingly i was snubbed yet again
i'm still holding out for hottest under
30.
but there's still a few great picks from
15 to 11 here goes don lemon
okay not off to a great start peter
ducey better
and at number 13 joy reid what
yes she influenced people to change the
channel
then
greg gotfeld
now we're talking and then after greg
rachel maddow now right off the bat
you're probably thinking two things
ducey should have been higher on the
list just based on his awesome hair
and also how is greg only one spot
higher than joy reid
i guess she probably got support from
the russian judges
in fact that's why greg's not here
tonight he was so blown away by the fact
that he wasn't higher on the list he
couldn't do the show thoughts and
prayers to greg and to that coffee table
he broke with his forehead
okay next five at number 10 you've got
jonathan call from abc he probably got
some votes that were meant for carl
jonathan
then
matt drudge a man best known for running
a website and wearing silly hats
and at number eight it's shawn hannity
can't argue with that
uh
i can't or he'll put me in a headlock
george stephanopoulos also from abc
and at six oprah winfrey never heard of
her
and here's the top five cnn chief
international correspondent clarissa
ward she was on the ground in
afghanistan for her coverage during the
withdrawal of u.s troops incredibly
biden didn't leave her behind
cnn boss jeff zucker whose hand must
hurt from all the pink slips he's been
signing
and then comes the real heavy hitters
fox news media ceo suzanne scott boom no
jokes there at least until she signs my
performance review
[Laughter]
then podcast king joe rogan all that
horse medicine is paying off
and at number one tucker carlson
how is a gutfield gutfeld guest
more influential than the host
as you probably realize this influential
list is dominated by fox as it should be
because we mopped the floor with all
those other places
um this is probably where the huge
audience would have been coming in handy
clapping
cheering
okay still i did feel like they may have
left a few notable influential
personalities off the list
jimmy fella for example for his outfits
alone thank you
here he is earlier in this year in one
notable performance
obviously he purchased the george
hamilton starter kit yeah i actually
look like a blow-up doll
jimmy looks like he was trying to deep
fry a turkey and fell in the fryer
i love it you know when you toast
s'mores jimmy you don't hold him with
your teeth
i think his skin is darker than jimmy
kimmel playing carl malone
all right
jimmy
uh what about this list i know you wish
you were on it stop it uh but it's i
love the fact that i mean the real
kicker is you got rogan
and you've got tucker these are the two
guys who they go against the narrative
and that's why they're most influential
no question there like you can't argue
with that and they have the numbers to
back them up everybody after that
um with the exception of suzanne and
greg and i'll get to greg in a minute
too everybody after that really doesn't
have much of an audience that's what i
was so fascinated by yeah is that you
know they basically threw all these cnn
people on there there were more cnn
people on the list than there are people
watching cnn right now
bizarre i was like who made you know
what kind of paola went into this list
but make no mistake about it for real uh
greg should be right next to tucker and
suzanne the guy actually saved late
night comedy for whatever whatever
people think if you're watching this
because you hate watch fox and this is
cheaper than going to the dominatrix
because we'll call your side a few names
along the way
he's the only one doing a late night
comedy show that anybody laughs at
anymore everybody else is doing a
partisan lecture disguised as comedy you
know and jimmy fallon is in a perpetual
hostage situation as you know he's funny
but they're not letting him do comedy
more often than not because he's got to
cater to that activist side of the left
you know seth wrote uh seth rogen seth
meyers is just a pandering beta
and stephen you don't have to go through
these no audiences
yes they do
they don't know anything no and colbert
is the comedy as oj is to marriage jokes
like he kills but not in a good way
i know all right katie the uh it is so
true they are influential only because
they are they're basically destroying
people's faith in media right so maybe
zucker has influence just in the weird
direction absolutely because people are
looking for something that's not like
tattletailing so i don't think you get
to go on the list like all the people on
cnn if all you do is talk about fox news
all day that doesn't that's not an
influential position to be in it's just
to kind of whine about what fox news is
doing what they're covering that's what
a lot of people on cnn are on the list
for but i'm upset that you took my my
line because i was going to talk about
jimmy's outfit there should be an
influential list about attire
i do look like the lead singer of a boy
band called in rehab yeah
yeah
but it works i stand by the purchase
shirt we have better we're both killing
it you'll park the car i'll check the
air and you're tired
fox is deserving of all the of all these
accolades and i'm not just saying that
because i'm here
yes you are
um we are as a network
deserving you know isn't number four
jeff sucker yeah he runs a network that
on any given night doesn't have a show
in the top 30
of shows on cable news but i generally
hate lists because the only list i'd
ever make is like most likely to get in
a fight on a bus
it's very easy to do these days schlapp
say something else good about this show
or fox
i think you know i i think you're being
a little hard on yourself i think you're
helping bring back the last elite it's
so true and i don't understand why some
of these late night comics aren't on
there as news personalities this is what
they are yeah they essentially are
reporting the news from their own slant
and i also think the other thing about
fox which is this
cnn i've done a lot of it
is so hate-filled and so focused on
starting race riots and race wars across
the country one of the things fox gets a
great reprieve for is just allowing
people to calm down yeah and watch the
five or watch something get some news
enjoy themselves and have it i think
that's needed hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else